I
they're friends it's a lisa malone and
boy do i have some suggestions for you
today hold on to your hats or whatever
you have on your head at the moment
because he has come some in a movie
stuff let's start with a movie that I've
mentioned once before on this show when
I went to the Savannah film festival
Jackie it's the biopic of Jackie Kennedy
starring the brilliant Natalie Portman
people like to believe in fairy tales
and you I believe that the characters we
read about on the page end up being more
real than the men you stand beside this
movie jobs back and forth in time but
the bulk of it takes place in the
aftermath of JFK's assassination her
husband died in her lap so
understandably she is grieving she's
trying to figure out how to deal with
his death at the same time she has to
organize a funeral in front of the whole
world there should be more horses more
soldiers are you doing this mrs.
Kennedy's more crying what cameras this
is making us look like our barracks
let's move with you end up doing I will
march with Jack known if the direction
is lovely by Pablo Lorraine and most
importantly it let snellie Portman shine
she has so many great monologues she's
got the gestures down she's got the
voice down but she makes it her own and
she really breathes life into this very
iconic figure
I'm guessing you won't allow me to write
any of that now because I never said
that another marvel of an actress is of
course Meryl Streep and you can see her
in full force in Florence foster Jenkins
which is out on video on demand this
week this is a little indie that
actually did really well at the box
office and it's one I think my mom will
like Sam um if you're watching note this
down maestro this is the talented young
man I was telling you about and let's
get started she's remarkable doesn't she
she can't be a little flat flash it
divides medical science this is based on
the true story of a New York socialite
who decides she wants to be an opera
singer despite not having a very good
voice Hugh Grant also co-stars but Meryl
Streep is the heart and soul of this
movie and she makes this film so bloody
charming to watch it's just a trick this
is what we live for isn't it
it's going very very very well
so Florence's voice is a horror but if
you're after a real horror movie then
check out the very creepy the eyes of my
mother which is available both in
theaters and on video on demand this
your mother yes why did she do she was a
surgeon in Portugal okay I we used to do
the sections together
happen to her
this movie is disturbing as hell but the
actress at the center of it is so lovely
and gentle and beautiful to watch her
name is [ __ ] margulies and she places
very lonely girl whose only friends
other people she kidnaps and performs
eye surgery on it's all minimal black
and white and it feels a bit like Alfred
Hitchcock but also like European cinema
sort of the spirit of the Beehive but
really disturbing I was fascinated by
out inside of the body looked she always
hoped I would be a certain one day
the eyes of my mother is a must for any
horror fans out there and I was lucky
enough to sit down with the director
Nicholas pest while i was at fantastic
fest kind of rhymes check it out my
world of heart that I love is like late
50s early 60s American Gothic like
William Castle night of the hunter
anything with Joan Crawford and Betty
Davis yeah night of the hunter is one of
the greatest horror movies that was ever
made and it's not like a slasher but
it's definitely a horror film and that's
very much what I was sort of going for
with this I think back to even like
Reservoir Dogs the ear getting cut off
and it's like a terrible pan to the
corner of the room and back and it was
like oh my god you see the ear get cut
off and you don't and after we premiered
at sundance and a guy came up to me I
was like I was with your movie until you
showed a guy getting stabbed so many
times and I was like I never showed that
anything that I could have shown is not
going to compare to you scaring yourself
recap time in theaters see Natalie
Portman in Jackie at home see Meryl
Streep in Florence foster Jenkins or go
out to the theater and brave be very
creepy the eyes of my mother it is so
worth it because my top 5 is still the
same as last week I thought I'd go out
on a limb and try to predict Best Lead
Actress at the moment here's how I see
the frontrunners in alphabetical order
Amy Adams in a rival Annette Bening in
20th century women not out yet Emma
Stone lala land not out yet Natalie
Portman Jackie out this weekend and ruth
negga in loving already been hopefully
still playing that's it for this week I
hope you guys have a really nice weekend
let me know in the comments below which
indie movies you are loving lately and
tweet me unleash him alone I'll see you
next time right